l'heure est au recueillement
en Corée du Sud.
Le pays entame une période
de deuil national après
la vie à plus de 150 personnes.
Sur les lieux du drame,
le président sud-coréen
l'ampleur des dégâts.
"Cette tragédie n'aurait
jamais dû se produire au coeur
de Séoul, dit-il. Mon coeur est
avec les familles des victimes,u
des êtres chers."
Il promet une enquête
rigoureuse pour déterminer
les causes de cette catastrophe,
une des plus graves
de l'histoire récente
de la Corée du Sud.
(cris paniqués)
La veille, la nuit a viré
au cauchemar à Itaewon,
un quartier connu pour
son atmosphère cosmopolite,
ses bars et ses lieux de fête
en tous genres.
Des milliers de jeunes réunis
pour célébrer la fête
de l'Halloween pour la première
fois depuis le début
de la pandémie deviennent
vite prisonniers des petites
rues étroites du quartier.
(coups de sifflet)
C'est la panique.
Certains tentent de fuir
par tous les moyens.
La bousculade s'ensuit,
des corps se retrouvent
inanimés au sol. au sol. au sol.
Me ALEXANDRA BÉLEC,
avocate canadienne à Séoul
- Après avoir vu les gens qui
s'acharnaient sur les massages
es et les ambulances
qui n'arrivaient pas à sortir,
j'avais du mal à "processer"
que ces gens-là pourraient
s'en sortir.- "J'ai perdu mes a,
pleure ce témoin.
"J'ai fait signe aux gens
de ne pas venir vers nous,
car je comprenais déjà ce qui
était en train de se passer.
mouraient."
Et cette tragédie
résonne à travers le monde.
Du Vatican, le pape François
a adressé ses condoléances
aux familles des victimes.
... écrit le premier ministre
Justin Trudeau. Le président
français, Emmanuel Macron,
et son homologue américain,
Joe Biden, ont aussi adressé
leurs condoléances au peuple
sud-coréen à la suite
de cette nuit d'horreur
qui restera longtemps
gravée dans les esprits.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mon